alex is on the line in California
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show Alex hi
Dave thanks for taking the call
certainly how can I help so I've been
pretty lucky I make a pretty good wage
as an engineer and I got some
inheritance within the last few years
it's been coming in from different
estate sales and I've been getting a
serious with my girlfriend but my
girlfriend is in a lot of debt so she's
got about a hundred thousand in student
loan debt from private university in a
field that doesn't pay well which what's
her feel and art okay so she spent a
hundred grand to get a degree in art
from a private university yeah okay and
and she's got some other debts and right
now she's unemployed I think she's been
paralyzed by the debt you know I've just
been listening to stories from different
callers and I just hear the echo from
from that you know okay so you don't you
feel like her hope is gone and in like
there's no sense in walking because I
can't climb Everest right yeah no you
don't think she's lazy I mean I I hope
not oh yeah
she has worked since I've been dating
everyone dating for like four years and
and I'm 28 now we're kind of getting to
that point where things are either gonna
get more serious or you know blessed I
guess I guess so I don't know I just
kind of looking at advice in that range
okay all right well I think I would just
have you know a loving conversation with
her it sounds like we're all pretty
serious and hey I'm worried about you
yeah yeah I know yeah women listen to
your bright you you know you've got all
this potential and you seem to have been
pear
realized by this debt and doing nothing
about it and it's not gonna fix itself
if your career is not what you thought
it was going to be then you you know
I'll walk with you well coach I'll be
your biggest cheerleader on getting a
different career but doing nothing is
probably not a plan yeah can you not
have that conversation yeah I I have I
have and it's you know it is a hard
conversation and she's very upset about
it and I think that's to me is what
shows that she does care and it's such
like a hard topic to talk about because
it's so emotional no well I think is you
just got to do something about it I mean
she has to do something about it and so
you know that there's there is more
anxiety more stress in feeling stuck and
sitting than there is in being
overwhelmed while you're running and so
we find people that their anxiety goes
down that it helps people that are
struggling with depression when they go
to work um even even if it's just an you
know if there's not something
emotionally you feel like doing but just
as an act of will as an act of personal
strength intestinal fortitude I get up
and I drag my butt out to the car I
start the car and I go to work and
there's something about that that is
helpful to the human psyche even if it's
not making a big dent today you're at
least in action you're in motion and
you're heading in the right direction
sitting and you know it's like you're
paralyzed a deer in the headlights
sitting in the road waiting to be run
over by an 18-wheeler is not a good plan
and so I you know if I'm in your shoes
my son is actually about your age okay
okay if he and I were sitting on the
back porch having this exact
conversation my advice to him father to
son
would be you lovingly have to help her
solve this because not solving it is a
deal-breaker yeah for the relationship
you told me that earlier you just didn't
use those exact words didn't you yeah
yeah yeah so I'm just making you say
that out loud to yourself and you don't
have to threaten her that's not what I'm
that's not the spirit
I want you have a spirit of help and you
want to help her be kind but it's a it's
a kind act to help her get off the couch
yeah baby doll you've got to go do
something you know you're not gonna make
it sitting here brooding and fearful and
sucking your thumb it's it's a it's a
human nature thing to do we all have
been terrified most of us have at some
point in our lives to where you feel
that way I remember that feeling where I
was just completely like crap no matter
what I do it's wrong my life looks like
a country song you know I mean it's just
like awful and so you you just it just
takes the wind out of your sails and
proverbs says Hope deferred makes the
heart sick that's what we're talking
about okay Hope deferred she doesn't
have hope yeah she feels stuck it feels
overwhelmed it can't it's a hopeless
situation but here's the rest of that
proverb when desire comes it is the tree
of life and that's what I was talking
about earlier when you can go okay in
spite of this I'm gonna have I'm gonna
manifest with intestinal fortitude down
in my guts the desire to get up and go
do something just to keep from getting
run over because I'm sitting in the
middle of the interstate something's got
to change
even if I just crawl over to the edge in
aller there a minute but at least
there's some motion right and so you
don't expect her to go get a new career
making $200,000 an hour in the next 20
minutes that is not what I expect normal
should you but I do expect to see her
deal with this otherwise what you're
gonna have five years from now is you're
gonna be married to a 35 year old
depressed lady yeah and you're gonna
deal with that for the next 20 years
that's where this is heading his
clinical depression if she doesn't deal
with it for her sake because it's a
human nature thing I mean I feel sorry
for I'm so sorry she's there but the bad
news is she's got her thousand dollars
in debt the great news is she's young
and smart and pretty and she can go do a
whole lot of things and she didn't have
to do anything with art she can or she
could do something with art I don't care
okay what she does but doing nothing I
do care about and that's what you're
saying and so give yourself a couple of
more tough conversations and see if you
see any movement at all because it it's
not things are either getting better or
they're getting worse and nothing does
status quo nothing stays the same
relationships get better they get worse
jobs get better they get worse your
money gets better it gets worse your
physical body is getting better getting
worse everything no one nothing stays
exactly where it was there's an it's
impossibility and so it sounds like
while you've been dating her that this
has gone downhill and you've got to help
return it for her sake and for the sake
of the relationship going forward that's
a dad talking okay and you can do this
and if I can help some way I will I mean
if you if you want to go through
Financial Peace University or something
I mean take her to that that anything
but it's gonna involve her her getting
over this paralysis and engaging again
and it's just hard to do when you're
hurting and scared and hopeless Hope
deferred makes the heart sick